[Music]
hey vogue it's kim we're here in my home
looks less i find that there's so much
chaos out in the world that when i come
home i want it to be just really quiet
and shockingly
four kids hasn't messed up my cream
house
cream
recently
north stayed home and had
yeah that's that's a really good
painting from a child yeah north sweetie
it's time for bed oh bro she wasn't
looking at the paper she was like
[Laughter]
her first vogue shoot is lame as hell
you just cut out squares and put them on
a piece of paper i'm not doing that for
my [ __ ] kid i did this live stream
once where i wiped your ass i changed
your diaper on live it was sick i saved
it
i'm here hanging with my child
north cove
what i ate the whole pregnancy
my first trip to the zoo we went all
right those pages look a little arizona
during the super bowl time we went to
the santa barbara zoo i really wanted to
archive these memories and it's just
it's really really cute so you know i
have each kid
has their own phone she just dumped that
[ __ ] on the ground yeah like i threw the
youtube yeah literally just from all
their baby showers to how their birth
announcement was hell yeah printouts of
instagram pictures so it's like so
interesting you'll see like emojis were
such a thing for saints and i announced
him with emojis
snapchat was such a thing
i guess i'd have to do it seems like
it's really about the kid doesn't it
seriously tick-tock announcement these
days you can see why i love to archive
all things for my kids they have the
best memories and i'll show you exactly
where i got it from
so my mom made this trunk for each of
my
us
oh my god dude
i just don't care
just kind of seems like a pr thing no
100
doesn't it look how good of a mom i am
kim k doing
thinly veiled pr no dude
no i mean don't you think if it was
anyone else and you actually made those
things
you wouldn't want to like show them off
so hard but yeah i did this for my
[ __ ] kid it's lame
yeah you know what i mean yeah wouldn't
you be like a little bit bashful about
it
or something yeah you might be like oh
yeah i have this weird hobby i like the
scrapbook yeah it's like whatever it's
just like a cool thing that my kids are
gonna look back on hopefully yeah we'll
see i don't know they might hate it it
definitely feels like a 10 second thing
in cribs where yeah they just like open
it up it's like you put his foreskin in
there and then close it you're like oh
what the [ __ ]
oh this is his first [ __ ] look at it
yeah about to have this like two minute
segment where you're like i love
scrapbooking i love but kim is like that
yeah it's just like her personality yeah
she's an alien yeah
i mean literally the most amazing place
no yeah definitely to really hang out
and i love cream yeah i love a cream i
love cream you know i didn't want your
typical basketball court i don't know if
you can see the material of the ground
but it's like spongy and i just wanted
it really neutral all my gym equipment
is black
so you can't bounce a ball on it
i just didn't want a noisy basketball
court because the ball is so many noisy
basketball courts out there in the real
world yeah regular people they're always
so noisy bouncing a ball so my kids love
to be out here and they're just like
throwing the ball on the ground it's
like
it's a balloon
the basketball hoops are black honestly
with like a cream little box and hoop
that part's called you know i just
wanted it to look
like it
cream hoop
someone dunks too hard man you broke my
mom's cream hoop she's gonna freak
you're gonna [ __ ] get murdered
not the cream hoop don't br
oh dude you busted my cream ooh
i can't believe you broke my cream hoop
dude bro you busted the cream hole this
is just like when it's summertime and
the pool's right here and the gym
connected to the basketball court music
blasting and kids are in the pool and me
and my sisters are like lunging up and
down the basketball court there's
nothing
more fun than a good workout day at my
house
what none of those events seem connected
that's the calabasas triathlon yeah yeah
yeah
first i throw my kids into the pool see
if they can swim i run a few drills on
the basketball court then i pick my
favorite springsteen song
yeah bro what the [ __ ] that's so cool
that they live at a ymca yeah
it's really awesome dude
and the other place out here that i
really wanted to show you guys is our
meadow up there so if you go up there
you'll see a huge vegetable garden so
many trees and so we grow our own fruits
and vegetables and
there's just a man chained there like
just like
help me
cuts off right in the middle of me
help me fruits and vegetables we grow
them this is like a lawyer like a lawyer
who [ __ ] something up for them
just tied to like a [ __ ] engine just
like he's not allowed to leave
[Laughter]
that's our meadow up there get it out
the camera kind of pans and then
see a dude is like moving and it's like
oh just move it back that way and
there's the look at the fruits and
veggies
it's painting and there's just like a
[ __ ] just a man like in like a
business suit but it's covered in dirt
just running to the camera
and then he gets like electrocuted by an
invisible fence
that's amazing nothing better than a day
where we come out here and pick the
veggies and
just a white guy in his mid 40s just in
a dirty business suit help me help me
help me
or like he's like maybe he's like
running across and there's just two
attack dogs chasing him
just like silence like this is my meadow
oh that's rufus yeah yeah and spot
they are so bad they are so bad it's the
most spoiled dogs you'll ever meet
wouldn't hurt a fly though
pick them and eat them just from there
[Laughter]
we do it together as a family all of the
cousins come over and we have little
baskets and
they just see how you really can like
farm
and eat it and eat it and eat it damn i
was watching this crazy ass video last
night from this guy
oh [ __ ] i forget his name [ __ ] hold on i
want to call him out because his channel
is really cool um but he was in the
poorest country on earth
which is a country in africa where the
average
average annual or average monthly income
is ten dollars american oh is this the
dude who's kind of like um
his name is discover with ruhi senate
burundi is the country's name yeah this
guy right here anyways he was like
interviewing these people ten dollars is
like a job that's like and and the
majority of the people i believe don't
even work
and he was talking to this
like old lady
who they grow food they don't know that
money exists
oh they grow
food so that they can feed themselves
and their kids that's it they have no
idea that like what commerce is like
how to exchange things they have no idea
what that is or what it means they don't
know what year it is
what the [ __ ] he said do they know what
year it is and they the translator asked
them and they were like no i didn't
just contrasting that to
yeah
we have all the cousins over just so
they know what it's like to like farm
fire and eat it and in it and basketball
and the spongy basketball court
hard cut
so do you guys like participate in any
kind of like
currency-based economy oh we're just
trying not to starve to death yeah no we
just we just grow our food it's pretty
wild yeah not knowing the year
that's kind of literally the only thing
that you're focused on is just surviving
yeah and making sure your kids survive
and not starve to death so one guy had
like nine kids and he's like yeah i lost
two already they starved to death
yeah oh my god crazy yeah it's really
good that kim kardashian has her own
personal farm though
you